when taking iphone portraits with
apple's studio lighting effects it's all
too often the same old story
unprofessional photo effects
[Music]
they're all bad with just about 30
worth of household items you can take
much more professional and natural
looking portraits
[Music]
hey siri make me professional
good head shots matter especially if
you're applying for jobs now
i'm trying to look the part or if you're
just trying to impress somebody on the
grams
so if you can't swing a professional
photographer right now you can just use
your iphone
our iphone cameras have gotten so good
and that's not just the pro models you
can take good photos with pretty much
any recent iphone
to take a photo like this all you need
are a few things from the hardware store
a special app that lets you shoot in raw
which is a different image format
and some fairly common household items
so let's get started
step one buy a quality light bulb head
online or to your local hardware store
and buy an led bulb with a high cri
and r9 rating you can find them at home
depot lowes and
even amazon the gist is cri is short for
color rendering index
it measures the light's ability to
illuminate colors accurately
the bottom line the higher cri and r9
rating the better and more flattering
the light will look on you
and your skin chances are you don't have
this kind of bulb at home but if you
want to check a bob that you do have
try and find the original box some sort
of rating should be printed on it
or you can just google the model number
so what's this gonna cost you
about 20 bucks for this high cri led
bulb and about 10
for this clamp light
step 2 download a raw friendly app
today we're going to be using halide
which is available for 5.99 in the app
store
halide gives you more manual controls
than the iphone's built-in camera app
like iso and shutter speed
it can also capture images in standard
formats like jpeg or htic
but adds an important third raw
raw also gives you tremendous power over
your images after you've taken them
you can easily change colors or the
white balance and recover dark shadows
or bright highlights
step three set up your lighting believe
it or not you can accomplish a lot with
just one light
and some curtains first find a space
where you can black out all available
light a dark
wall or fabric is great if you have one
but if not just use any old wall curtain
or fabric
the less reflective the better second
find something you can affix the clamp
light to
like a coat rack
third put your light at a 45 degree
angle above and a 45 degree angle to the
side of your subject
now you're gonna want to diffuse the
light until any shadows across your face
soften up without any diffusion the
shadows are way too harsh and unnatural
let's add a piece of parchment paper to
help soften it up a little
ah that looks a little better now let's
add a white t-shirt
if you don't have anything to put the
diffusion shirt on you'll need another
person to hold it
sadly cloning isn't possible ah that
looks much better
you can use pretty much any sheer white
fabric to diffuse light
sheets work really well too now either
with the help of a friend or a tripod
open halide and frame up your shot if
you don't have someone to help you take
the photo but you do have a tripod why
not have siri lend a hand
open the app's advanced settings and set
up the siri shortcut feature
hey siri make me professional
you can use the auto settings in the app
or you can adjust the manual controls
oh and if you don't want to get fancy
with all this raw stuff you can use the
default camera app as well
those photos turned out pretty darn well
too
don't worry if that raw image looks a
little flat we'll get to that in the
next step
step four edit your photo since raw
isn't a standard format you're going to
need a special application with a raw
processor to open it
for the sake of cost let's go with one
of my favorites darkroom which is free
but if you want to use the fancy filters
it'll cost you a few bucks
first i crop the image you lose some
resolution but for most web applications
and social
this is fine then i used one of
darkroom's filters
from there thanks to the power of raw i
was able to heavily adjust the exposure
and bring in
some of the highlights and voila
a studio lit portrait that now won't
make you the laughing stock of linkedin
this is just a tiny glimpse into the
wonderful world of studio lighting try
it out on your own or with friends kids
whomever send them to me
have fun